I know that this road has been very hard
and yet here you are building This
Magnificent family
what's going on in that head of yours
something a little piece of it he said
Dad
they're not afraid of anything
but I am
afraid of losing someone I love
Dominic Toretto you're about to learn
all about fear
boom you such a beautiful life filled
with love and family I never got that
chance
you stole that from me
my future
my family
and now
I'm gonna break yours
by peace
[Music]
he's coming for you with everything
what's the plan Dom I'm not sure anymore
one of us might not come back from this
but we have to fight
[Music]
never accept death
suffering as old
[Music]
he's trying to tear us apart
when it used to be about winning we
raced for respect
today I race to stop the Bloodbath
[Music]
problem with having such a big family
how do you choose the ones you save
Let's Race
thank you
[Music]
you still know how to drive
what do you think
it's showtime
recognizes again
[Music]
I'm coming for you son
best time
here they come you will never be able to
break my family
good morning sunshine you gotta be
kidding me
foreign